شروط كريم عدم الانتشار ، هل سيكون
فعالًا أيضًا أو على الأقل لبعض الوقت
إذا لم يتم التصدي لرغبات دول
أخرى
في المنطقة مثل المملكة
العربية السعودية التي تثير القلق من بئر إيران النووية المحتملة ،
فمن
المحتمل أن يكون لبرنامجها النووي سلاح لمتابعة ما
لديها.  الأسلحة النووية الخاصة التي
تضع غطاءً على برنامج إيران النووي
هو أمر جيد ولكن مرة أخرى
إنها ليست استراتيجية شاملة
وأعتقد أنه فيما يتعلق بالدول الإقليمية ،
فأنت تعرف ما سيقولونه هو
أنهم ليسوا قلقين من المملكة العربية السعودية والإمارات العربية المتحدة
.  لست قلقًا بشأن تعرض
إيران للقذائف النووية ، فأنت تعلم أنهم قلقون بشأن
وكلاء إيران الإقليميين واستخدام إيران
الدقيق المتزايد للصواريخ
والصواريخ والطائرات بدون طيار ، لذا إذا
تم إحياء هذه الصفقة بالفعل ، فأنا لا أعتقد أنها
ستؤدي بالضرورة إلى إثارة
الدول المجاورة للولايات المتحدة.  شركاء
في المنطقة لتحسين
برنامجهم النووي ، لكني
أعتقد أن القلق الذي يمثل
مصدر قلق شرعي للانقلاب الإقليمي
ntries هو أننا نطلق العنان لإيران
اقتصاديًا لمضاعفة وثلاث
مرات على كل هؤلاء الوكلاء
والصواريخ والطائرات بدون طيار التي
يستخدمونها يوميًا